à tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle quelqu'un
J'ai 19 ans
[Musique]
qui convient
toi stade de concert Samuel pourquoi tu
maintenant la vidéo so polish Istanbul Elif
Il n'y a pas de plus beau système d'exploitation Android
reportage vidéo interview avec moi ou quelque chose comme ça
j'espère qu'ils l'ont bien fait
[Musique]
Je me sentais juste comme une célébrité
un peu
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à mes vidéos
n'oubliez pas d'aimer
[Musique]
Il est comme moi il y en a des milliers de milliers
les filles sont restées parce que ça vient du serveur
emprisonné pour avoir prié
maintenant agressé par des hommes
[Musique]
peut être plus jeune que toi, moins de filles
nous avons peut-être des sœurs aînées
Notre mère peut trouver le secret après avoir été stérilisée
ses prières
abonnez-vous Dieu Dieu est très libre de votre cœur
nous vivons mille grâces à Allah
il est donc nécessaire
Merci
[Musique]
il est
Je prends la série sur le terrain de ton premier pas en ce moment
S'il n'y a pas de matinée pour postuler
Bravo après ça si tu ne travailles pas
je l'ai décrit
Nous l'avons dans la prochaine vidéo comme celle-ci
[Musique]
nous disons anciens Turcs
chose de pensée
[Musique]
Ma mère et mon père sont aussi en haut à droite, je suis très
Je l'ai adoré, comment peut-il tenir etc.
ou poser des questions idiotes
a commencé
C'était très bien, mais quand je suis monté sur Elif pour la première fois
comme ça va exploser
[Musique]
Je suis allé à l'école
Ils étaient maintenant très proches
mes amis ici
bazlamas on va au ciné
des fois on fait des tournées de merde des fois
on sort manger
un
[Musique]
mon amie Rabia
Je vais rencontrer au lycée très utile pour moi
J'étais turc j'avais un peu de mal à la poésie
Alors pour la première fois je me suis assis à côté de toi vide
ici je vais parler de notre vente
Alors pourquoi connaissais-tu ces sentiments
avant avant en colère je savais en fait
pas si en détail
Nous avons du mal à nous y habituer parce que je pense pourquoi
Il y a quelque chose que je vis pour toi
Tu viens, je me bats, c'est si dur
Quelque chose
à ce sujet maintenant
De toute façon, à la suite de le prendre, nous sommes un peu mieux tout seuls
ou ça ne touche pas trop nos sentiments
[Musique]
Comment
connaissance pardon ce tel ici chaque
Que fait ta mère quand tu viens ?
Quand je dis faire un travail ou quelque chose
Je disais parfois
Je pleurais mon ami dit Hodja
ne demande pas, je reçois
parce que je veux dire que ce sont de belles choses et que votre
pour
[Musique]
Je suis né et j'ai grandi là-bas école primaire là-bas
Je l'ai fini parce que c'est si beau, l'endroit est si beau
Je serais toi, nous nous amusions tellement
[Musique]
que tout le monde
ils coupent toujours tout le monde
eh bien ils le sont aussi nous sommes en colère contre ma mère maintenant
mon frère
Vous avez fait le nôtre, vous savez, ici
Turquie
il est
[Musique]
envoie nous ici selon le désir du temps
faire lire
[Musique]
Je veux
2014 maman
43 Mon frère est venu vers leur père, nous deux
nous sommes restés là quand irai-je bébé
fabriqué
je le faisais pendant que j'y étais
Les choses commencent à se resserrer
comme ça, rue par rue, partout
commencé à devenir flics
La Turquie a arrêté ceux qui sont venus et lentement
commencé à arrêter avec Dieu pardonne
Ayvalı très bon Premier écrasant social
network Site world Mais un beau Polygone
suffisant
c'est là-bas avec bonheur
Qui a dit que je m'accrochais à ma mère
J'irai
Demande
notre père t'a lu une fois et est parti
Fin 2016, les choses sont un peu mitigées.
Demande
Je lis en silence, sois étudiant, commerce
quiconque fait n'importe quoi
que ce soit un homme, ils ont commencé à pendre en prison
qu'est-ce qu'un crime d'être musulman
prié, est allé à la mosquée, on lui a demandé
ils ont aussi des sushis
Cette
puis jamais Ben 17 fin janvier
quelque chose devait aller
Maman nous sommes m&m ne pars pas si quelque chose arrive
tu ne peux rien faire ici t'occuper de mes enfants
Je ne regarde pas la Turquie disait cette chose Mon père était un
rien ne se passe je ne fais rien
dis-je contre eux.
l'avion de mon père avec du fer la nuit Mon père aussi
mon frère va m'emmener
au travail après la mariée
il y avait déjà une tâche supplémentaire
De là, l'aéroport vous emmène directement soit
[Musique]
Quoi
nous ne pouvons pas nous rencontrer à temps
Est-il resté dans la recherche ou est-il mort ?
Est-il encore en vie ? Nous ne le connaissons pas du tout.
donc on ne sait pas
Et ça ne s'estompe pas, je reçois 10 géants de l'amour
de quoi tu parles bro emiko vertu et
Problème de poussette vivante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu changes et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salles quand cela
des troupes je suis plus rapide que lui pour toi
je ferai
tu oublies tout
Pas du tout un homme en tant qu'hommes
quelque chose de fort ou quelque chose d'endurance
capable de faire un peu
[Applaudissements]
Chose
Il convient dans
Quand vous venez, il est très confortable d'entrer à l'intérieur.
chemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi ça arrive
il est
Je jure que tu es l'homme sur la photo
Suite
je leur apprends des choses
être dans le même environnement que les gens
c'est ainsi que nous ne partageons pas le même environnement
prendre une bonne raclée à chaque personne
tri merci beaucoup
Je n'aime pas toujours mon père non plus
la fille se battait et disait
je le dis aussi j'adore quoi
Il disait "Faisons-le" Ma mère était aussi très occupée au début.
a fait quelque chose
[Musique]
Par exemple, nous faisons du sport avec des hommes.
si j'étais là il ne serait pas capable de faire une chose pareille
Il ne pouvait pas le faire quand il a dit Özgür
ces problèmes d'utilisation mon garçon
Mais l'homme est partout
Bien sûr, il ne veut pas d'obstacles car
Il le dit alors nous prenons le bus
besoin de ça
[Applaudissements]
On a vu que les envies sont parties et il adore ça
est-ce que tu t'allonges
il s'est juste levé un peu et a vu faible
alors comment ça se fait que je suis étonné
Comment aller au magasin hate Kin en un jour
je le dirai en secret
[Musique]
Bonjour les amis aujourd'hui ma chaîne
bienvenue
cette glace n'a pas sa place chez Uyghur
bien d'accord
Oui
[Musique]
maintenant je vais leur montrer l'arrêt Uighur
J'irai, si beau Emir, je l'ai compté
[Musique]
Oui oui ça l'est
C'est très gentil
sommes-nous un oui je le présente à ma soeur
rencontré les bons gars allons-y
au temps
Le frère de Sibel Can a dit si tu viens tôt
mieux
nous allons, voici la chose du milieu que vous voyez
la bonne nouvelle de faire une telle activité
ils l'ont fait pour visiter
Nous allons
droit dans la casserole
en disant
je n'ai jamais rien pour réparer la machine
J'ai découvert que tu l'avais fait Oui c'est venu maintenant
je me retire
que penses-tu de ton frère
rien
frère frère soeur intelligent quoi
Quel frère pensez-vous
ça tire très bien les lumières sont allumées
branche à glisser
En fait, tu t'en sortiras mieux.
qu'en est-il de mon frère, il peut faire
Je cherche à donner des agneaux tu penses
si qui
Non
Qu'en pensez-vous
Merci
peut être
[Musique]
tout effacé à l'avenir
nous volons ce pantalon le fromage
nous savions
avec un peu de chance
Prière
prouve le
Web Whatsapp
Beaucoup
vous travaillez
aller
comment fait-on quelque chose
Par exemple, Ak là-bas, à des parents là-bas
nous ne pouvons même pas le joindre parce que
rencontrer des parents ou quelque chose de sale
ils ont peur
nous faisons quelque chose avec compréhension
On te salue c'est normal tu sais mon père c'est quelque chose
une personne qui aime tweeter les enfants
il aimait beaucoup ma mère ma mère
dit et si mon père était dehors
quoi que vous fassiez, peu importe ce que vous nous faites
nous avions l'habitude d'essayer d'atteindre l'extérieur également de télécharger
Aller
s'abonner
il est
nous nous sentons libres en même temps
on a très envie d'y aller
comme nous pouvons obtenir notre éducation
Nous pouvons vivre avec le style de vie
l'un l'autre
Il est donc important de transmettre notre amour
amusant de vous faire sentir que vous n'êtes pas seul
donc notre famille n'est pas ensemble
Cette situation la plupart d'entre nous, alors qu'est-ce que l'autre
nous nous connaissons comment nous nous sentons
Mais et donc réconfortez-vous les uns les autres
nous pouvons être, nous avons des rêves aussi
combien de tes rêves ont été brisés
bien dans le cas mais toujours 3A
nous devons le connecter au travail
atteindre notre rêve
merci c'est ce que tu dis
C'est assez pour aujourd'hui
bébé non je l'ai
le sais et à partir de maintenant je le ferai
Pensez à gérer
De l'argent pour des fruits Mon mez je n'aime pas ça
tu l'aimes frère Sense
[Musique]
à tous
j'ai pris
Amoureux
Paroles
mon amour mon père
Non
À présent
je ne sais plus ce que c'est
il est
[Musique]
est-ce que tu te prends la tête du groupe Hey j'ai peur que ce soit si bon
tu sais qu'il est resté avec toi
[Musique]
Il se fâche à nouveau Sun est encore plus
tu fais je
Je ne peux pas sortir de l'effet de quelque chose comme ça
quelque chose à une personne qui pense beaucoup
même si tu penses comme ça pendant 23 jours ou quelque chose comme ça
réveille toi je fais ça
Nous recommençons cette action face à certains
les gens ont peur, mais certaines personnes
ça sort comme une surprise, par exemple, nous aussi
il n'y avait pas grand chose avant
Après l'école c'est déjà arrivé
nous ferons quelque chose d'eux
en disant
nous avons commencé à sortir ensemble
[Musique]
s'abonner
finalement
mcb-8 bébé
[Applaudissements]
appelle nos enfants
[Musique]
Je suis là-bas certains enfants n'ont pas l'air peu
avec mes enfants, certains enfants n'ont pas de mère
il n'y a personne, les enfants sont laissés
maintenant mon frère est en vacances pendant trois mois à la fête
y était allé
il a un ami maintenant je le veux
[Musique]
certains intérieurs car ils sont très petits
nous sommes nés pas vu pour autant que je sache
Il s'y est habitué, ça n'arrive pas autant que nous
La Turquie maintenant
être le champion
Ils veulent être ce papier après ça
Docteur qui veut être footballeur puis quelqu'un
il a dit que je serais un patron
nous l'avons collé ici est le plus riche du monde
personne riche on écrivait parfois son nom
J'ai vu des enfants aussi
Je les plains quand ils étaient si jeunes
être avec tes parents
même si nous étions intéressés
Il ne prend pas la place d'une mère et d'un père.
La médecine des moudjahidines est tirée 110000000 fisson
Si je dis donne une voyelle à l'infini, donc le dernier F
En fait, quand je suis venu ici
Je suis venu avec un ami de la chose de mon père
son ami est allé en Europe c'est ici
Ma grand-mère est venue avant moi
elle regardait puis elle a disparu un par un
c'est moi ici mujahid il alors
quelque chose est notre livre préféré
je veux des photos
ils ont mis les photos sur nos vêtements
Si tu veux être bon, je te sauverai à l'avenir
je veux l'être
Je vais le jeter à ton lion
Parce que je suis tellement curieux de l'espace, quel endroit
est
et si tu deviens astronaute comme ça, beaucoup d'argent
peut gagner et mon truc de famille
je peux regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savez-vous un peu avant
c'était fatiguant au début j'en vois beaucoup
puis tire lentement tu vois
j'ai commencé maintenant quand je suis si fatigué
je vois que j'ai vu la dernière fois
mon père ne peut pas reconnaître le jour où il est venu
Nous avons vu beaucoup de critiques que je ne pouvais pas supporter
Le nôtre je dis que j'ai gagné
alors je ne te connais pas
après ça j'ai fait un rêve la nuit
il était très malade san ou après ça son
Allez environ quatre ou cinq jours après l'effet
donc je ne pouvais pas sortir
[Musique]
être intelligent
versé parce qu'il
[Musique]
et alors
c'est le soleil les voies ferrées il y en a d'autres
défendre les gens
essayant d'arrêter, nouveau nouveau essayant de travailler
J'ai commencé
n'est-ce pas et
Cela ne fait que 3 semaines, commençons d'abord
nous sommes entrés dans notre quatrième semaine d'exécution
il est Çalışkan Zeki, grâce à lui
alors parce que son coeur est bon aussi
aider les infirmières
qu'est-ce qu'on en aide à manger de la viande
puis mars? Après cela, l'hôpital
Je dis que je m'enfuis avant mon frère
Je deviens quelque chose comme ça ou plus de science je dirais
Y a-t-il quelque chose que je ferai mais maintenant
nous avons encore besoin d'aide
économie très mauvaise puis-je demander
Parce qu'il faut en prendre beaucoup
pas un salaire militaire
2850 km
Je voulais récupérer ça, que dois-je être
voulait 1750 TL nous le ferons dans la rue
si vous voulez l'acheter déjà nous rentrons à la maison
J'ai honte Pas de professeur, je le ferai
quand il y a de l'argent quand je travaille
J'ai dit que je viendrais te chercher ce soir
Enlève tes vêtements, je suis rentré chez moi, j'ai dit à ma sœur
il a dit que je l'avais acheté ou quelque chose comme ça
J'ai dit oui, de la moitié de son salaire
aller trop loin
[Musique]
Pourrait-il être plus d'un millier
mais
J'ai frappé Android, tu l'aimes, laisse-moi l'écrire
tout va bien avec sa maman pas de [ __ ]
son brocoli Gizem tournait No ya
ennui
plus tard
je veux faire
je veux Je veux
[Musique]
je pense
Je marche dans notre avenir
mon père est faible
mais ici je le vois maintenant
[Musique]
je vais rejoindre une équipe
je rejoins tu dois travailler dur
je vais travailler je vais travailler ça arrive lentement
tout
[Musique]
il est il est